Прізвище президента України Петра Порошенка
фігурує у кількох корупційних скандалах.
DW вирішила згадати найгучніші з них.
Журналістське розслідування "Paradise Papers"
розкрило дані про офшори чиновників з усього світу.
Серед них і українського президента Петра Порошенка.
На думку журналістів "Слідство.Інфо",
які брали участь у розслідуванні, президентський офшор
насправді  створювали  для мінімізації податків,
а не для передачі  Roshen в сліпий траст, обіцяної  Порошенком.
За даними ЗМІ, юридична фірма,
яка представляє інтереси українского президента,
спочатку  намагалася заснувати офшор на острові Мен.
Проте там отримала відмову.
Пізніше аналогічне прохання вона направила
панамській фірмі Mossack Fonseca,
яка зрештою і допомогла створити заплановану структуру.
Історія з викриттям офшору для кондитерскої корпорації
президента почалася іще півтора роки тому.
Його створювали у 2014 році,
у розпал запеклих боїв на Донбасі.
Це випливало з так званих "панамських документів".
За даними журналістів, для володіння "Roshen"
юристи українського президента вибудовували складну схему
з фірм у Нідерландах, на Кіпрі та Віргінських островах.
Журналісти ще тоді припускали,
що президент хоче уникнути сплати податків в Україні.
Однак і глава держави, і його юристи це заперечували.
Не минулося і без скандалів, пов’язаних із "5 каналом".
Німецька газета Frankfurter Allgemeine торік повідомила,
що працівникам президентського телеканалу досі
виплачують частину зарплати "у конвертах".
Факт отримання грошей на різні банківські картки
офіційну та неофіційну - виданню підтвердили
семеро колишніх та нинішніх журналістів "П’ятого".
У німецькому виданні вважають,
що це робилося для уникнення сплати податків.
Проте отримати офіційні пояснення газеті не вдалося.
В Адміністрації Президента журналістам порадили звернутися
за роз’ясненнями до телекомпанії,
але і там жодних коментарів не надали.
Закиди на адресу президента не обмежуются лише бізнесом.
Як з’ясували торік українські репортери, Петро Порошенко
має віллу на півдні Іспанії, яку він ніколи не вказував
у своїй декларації про доходи.
Будинок оформлений не на українского гаранта,
а на пов‘язану з ним іспанську фірму.
У фінансових звітах компанії вказано, що двоповерхова вілла
у середземноморському архітектурному стилі
оцінена у 4 мільйони євро.
І це лише неповний перелік корупційних підозр
стосовно чинного президента України.